how does chef Stefan some chefs do coke
hey guys my name is jii Osasco I'm chef
here in Los Angeles California
hi I'm gentleman and I am a pastry chef
based in Highland Park California and
today we're going to be answering some
of the most commonly googled questions
about cooking
why do you cook lobsters alive we cook
lobsters alive because if you cook them
dead they do not taste good and you want
your seafood to be as fresh as possible
you can kill it humanely right before it
goes into the water but you don't want
to buy ever dead Lobster what is the
best cooking oil I think it depends what
you're going to be cooking avocado oil
has a pretty high smoke point so
generally that would be the type of oil
that you should be using at your house
grapeseed oil is a great neutral oil for
high temperature cooking Syrian sauteing
and olive oil is just all-purpose and
it's good for you or you know if you're
trying to be a little more frugal canola
oil works just as well when cooking
how does chef Stefan not every chef is
thin first of all I think that the
chef's that are the Finnis are probably
the ones that tried to balance the
kitchen life with their personal life so
they actually work out and run a lot I
know a lot of chefs that are runners
early early in the morning there's a lot
of time spent on your feet a lot of time
running around a lot of time eating out
of a deli container and skipping meals
not even realizing it you're working
long hours and you know often you won't
eat during those long hours and some
chefs do coke what is the healthiest way
to cook an egg I think any cooking
method that would use no additional fat
so you can hard boil it you can poach it
you can soft boil it a 68 degree
egg your egg yolk should not be cooked
all the way it should still be a little
bit gooey and yummy and a little bit
soft so like a soft-boiled egg is pretty
healthy I would say how do chefs use
math oh that's a good question
that's great great question I hate math
I'm not really a math person but chefs
definitely use math in the kitchen if
you have to double or triple the recipe
or reduce it by half math goes into that
and the next thing you know you're doing
math very quickly in your head chefs use
math for percentages oftentimes recipes
will have a percent of hydration for
dough's a percent of salt for cooking or
brining so the biggest way that chefs
use math is to figure out the percentage
of something how much salt percentage in
a water brine how much vinegar
percentage in a pickle or how much
pepper percentage in a sausage I would
definitely say that my math has gotten
better being pastry chef because doing
pastry and desserts requires a lot of
more measurement and precision than
other types of cooking should you cook
for your dog yes if you have the time I
highly recommend cooking for your dog
dogs are animals and they need protein
and fat and if you can cook for them
they'll be much better because then you
are making sure just like with human
food that there are no chemicals and
preservatives you can cook for your dog
you don't need to cook for your dog if
you're cooking for your dog make sure
it's cooked well done that you don't add
any salt that you don't add any oil that
you don't add anything I hear dogs
really like eggs and plain rice I think
that's probably the most commonly cooked
meal that I've seen for dogs so what I
hope people will appreciate from my work
is that I actually put a lot of love and
work into making sure that everything is
fully cooked it tastes great and looks
great it means a lot to me to be able to
give it to you and you just really enjoy
it and know that it was made with love
I use Google the internet every day as a
source of inspiration so all in all the
internet is not all bad use Google take
it with a grain of salt
but don't believe everything that you
see on the
[Music]
[Music]